ماذا ترك لكم الوالد من املاك اقصد ترك
لنا ارث كبير
في حب الناس
في رضاء الله
فالقيمه المعنويه الكبيره اللي قدم حياه
الخاطرها هذا احلى ارث بالدنيا
الحمد لله احنا ناس يعني
وعزازين مكرمين اخوتنا العرب كلهم حزينه
اخوتنا في الخليج العربي
في الوطن العربي
الكل يحترم ويقدر ماكو مكان اروح له اذا
مو الاقي احترام وتقدير كبير ولو لا حفاظا
على خصوصيه الاخوه في ذلك لكنت حكيت لكم
مواقف رائعه
من من زعماء عرب من زعماء عرب لكني ساكتفي
بهذا القدر حفاظا على لانه المجالس امانات
لما الاخ
يشرح موضوع يثق باخته اخته لازم تكون على
قدر عالي من تلك المسؤوليه
بالعكس الكل يحترم الكل
الكل قدره والكل يعتبره ان وجوده مهم لا
اقصد فقط اختنا في الخليج العربي في الوطن
العربي
يعتبرون انه هذا الرجل هو الدرع الحصين
للامه العربيه بغيابه استباحه الامه
استباحها كل من هبوده هذا يعني
[موسيقى]
الاملاك الاموال لانه بعد سقوط بغداد
العالم شاهد في قصور صدام حسين كان هناك
اسلحه كلاشنكوفات مصنوعه من الذهب
ليس يعني حكي الكثير معقول يعني لم تاخذوا
اي شيء من هذا لم تحصل على شيء بعد هذا من
هذه الاموال راح اجاوبك
مثل المال والذهب
المال والذهب اليوم موجود ممكن مو موجود
ممكن اليوم مو موجود بكره يكون موجود لكن
انتم عائله بحاجه الى مصاريف بحاجه الى
عيش كريم
يعني
انت بحاجه الى الى يعني دعم مادي بحاجه
الدول العربيه احنا ما تركنا لم تاخذوا
شيء الدول العربيه ما يتركون اخواتهم احنا
اهلهم هم اهلنا
ما راح يتركونا للاقدار اما ناخذ ونملك
بالنسبه للوالد سؤالك عن الوالد الوالد
اكو احتلال واكو دوله تعتبر ضد فتره حكمه
والسنين طويله لها هاي الدوله
لولادين القصور مسجله باسم الوالد
كان ما يحتاج اني اطلع بالعربيه واقول
عندنا قصور باسم الرئيس صدام حسين كان
تسابقوا ان يعرضون املاك الوالد الوالد
ولا متر بارض العراق مو بس هاي قصور
الدوله مثلها مثل اي دوله ثريه بالعالم
كل الدول الثريه بالعالم بها قصور لكن
القصور كلها اسم الديوان تابعه للدوله مو
باسم الرئيس
والاسلحه اللي ذكرتها حضرتك هاي مو للقتال
مو اللي جبهات القتال هاي يصنعها تصنيع
العسكري اولا هي مو مستورده ومو كلفه
خياليه مثل ما تعتقدون هي تصنيع عراقي
مطليه بالذهب اصبح الان يضع الطلاء بالذهب
على الاكل في بعض المطاعم صح ما اقصد
المطاعم الغاليه والمستثناء بالله صرنا
نشوفها بالسوشال ميديا وكل مكان وهذه
هدايا لرموز لاشخاص يعني ناس معينين وما
هي ما هي قصه على بلد تري مثل العراق احنا
العراق كله
اهم شيء عندنا من شماله الى جنوبه بالكرد
والشيعه والسنه شنو ذهب امي يعني الامير
كان في لحظه اخذه وكل ذهبها كل ممتلكاته
ولا رفت عينه